-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
The Conservative Political
Action Conference, or CPAC,
kicked off today in Texas,
and former president Trump will
speak on the last day
of the event.
He's expected to talk about
taxes, gun rights, immigration,
Bugs Bunny, pretzels, the 2003
Chevy Camaro, Mr. Met,
Selina Gomez,
the canceled "Batgirl" movie,
and the final episode of "MASH,"
and lastly,
why hot dogs are sandwiches.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden tested positive
for the coronavirus again
yesterday.
Or as he's thinking of it,
a second term.
[ Laughter ]
Former vice president Mike Pence
is expected to hold
a fundraiser later this month
in the Hamptons.
So if you think you bumped into
Mike Pence in the Hamptons
this month,
that's just what every man
in the Hamptons looks like.
[ Laughter ]
The Senate yesterday ratified
Finland and Sweden's application
to join NATO in a 95-1 vote with
Republican Senator Josh Hawley
the only lawmaker
to oppose the move.
Well, he's always been an every
man for himself kind of guy.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
The CDC this week is reportedly
expected to ease its coronavirus
guidance recommendations.
Though I don't know how it could
be any more eased.
Nobody's wearing masks.
The restaurants are full.
Do they want us to kiss
the waiter before we order?
[ Laughter ]
Today was former president
Barack Obama's 61st birthday.
Said Obama,
"Joe, it's 3:00 a.m."
[ Laughter ]
"But I was the first one.
Right, pal?"
[ Laughter ]
"First birthday wish of
the year, right?
This job is so hard, buddy."
[ Laughter ]
"Keep getting coronavirus."
[ Laughter and applause ]
It was announced yesterday that
the long-running soap opera
"Days of Our Lives"
will move next month
from NBC to the streaming
platform Peacock.
So if you're a big fan of
"Days of Our Lives,"
you're never going to
find Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
"Is it channel eight?"
"No, Grandma,
it's not a channel."
"What?"
[ Laughter ]
A Chick-fil-A restaurant
in North Carolina is facing
criticism after it was looking
for volunteers to work
at the location's drive-through
who'd be given five free entrees
for a one-hour shift
instead of being paid.
Perhaps most offensive --
calling a sandwich from
Chick-fil-A an entree.
[ Laughter ]
The discount department store
corporation that operates
T.J. Maxx, Marshall's,
and HomeGoods recently agreed
to pay a $13 million fine
for selling
recalled infant sleeper
products.
Okay, I knew this felt unsafe.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview, Green Bay
Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers said that
his experience taking
the psychoactive tea ayahuasca
led him to having
the best football season
of his career.
As opposed to Tom Brady
who credits a mysterious
painting up in his attic.
[ Laughter ]
Tomorrow is
National Underwear Day.
Already?
Man, it really creeps up on you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And finally -- Don't encourage.
And finally, a woman
in Minnesota has set
a Guinness world record for
world's longest fingernails.
Also, world's worst texter.
And that --
[ Laughter ]
That was the monologue,
everybody.